in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Toby
and Christie are with us hey guys how
are you okay Dave how are you better
than I deserve Merry Christmas Christmas
to you what do you guys live we live in
White Plains Kentucky just a little bit
north of Hopkinsville oh very cool not
too bad a drive tonight about two hours
of soda Gator COO good good and here to
do a debt free scream yes sir how much
have you paid off we've paid off just a
little bit over a hundred and sixty six
thousand dollars we had a house we sold
in in Kansas City that was a hundred and
nineteen and thirty six thousand and
student loans we had a little bit of
braces and a used car we bought two okay
very cool and how long did it take you
to do all of this took us thirty four
months Dave okay
making what kind of money we make right
now go ahead Christie
take-home pay is about sixty thousand
dollars but we have benefits with his
job like a parsonage for instance okay
okay so you're probably bumping up
around 280 total pay then something like
that okay excellent very very good so
tell me what happened thirty four months
ago tell me your story
well I have a had a friend several
friends at my old work at Kansas City I
worked for hi V food stores and one of
my good friends went through a Financial
Peace University and he just kind of
told us about it and I didn't really
think a whole lot of about it until one
of my other buddies was going through
and he was doing his own deal and he
would put away twenty dollars here he
would put away a hundred dollars here
that type of thing and I got to thinking
man we could do a little bit better with
with saving and I was driving down 435
on Kansas City and I saw your picture
with a Financial Peace University and I
thought you know what let me let me try
to get that book and read a little bit
about it and and I bought the book off
Amazon and we got it in and Christie
read it in a night this is what you've
been looking for huh tell me about that
well I when he first ordered the book I
didn't know why it was ordering it
because I thought we were doing pretty
good I mean we did never have late
payments you know we didn't carry
balances on credit cards but when it
came in I just picked it up and started
reading it I read I finished at about
two o'clock in the morning I just
read it straight and that was when I
went ahead and did the ELP for the real
estate to sell the house in Kansas City
and he woke up to a voicemail from a
realtor I didn't know she was doing a
tour a book and go to sleep wake up in
the house got salt yeah so this a woman
of action right that's fun
and and so that gets the house gone
that's 160 119 of the 166 and how did
you plow through the rest of that over
the period of time what'd you do
well we just got on a written budget we
had a plan that was the main thing that
we really enjoyed is that we did pretty
good but we just didn't have a plan and
when we sat down and we did the zero
based budget we just found money and it
was like like you say we just got a
raise and we put all of it right towards
that debt and and it went went really
good there are times where you know
things pop up and you get discouraged
you you think okay we're gonna save this
much towards towards the debt towards
the lowest one of the snowball and you
know something would pop up we get a
little discouraged then the next month
would you know we'd have a better month
so it was it was good okay very cool so
now you got teenagers tell me your
teenagers names and ages this is Maya
she just turned 17 this week and Joel is
14 okay and so how much do they hate
Dave Ramsey every dollar thing she has a
part-time job and she actually does
pretty good with her budget
well she's 17 she's virtually a grown-up
so she's got this okay very cool good
well welcome this is very cool so what
advice do you give people when they hear
you've paid off all this debt and they
ask you how you did it how do you get
out of debt well this is the main thing
for us was just having a plan and the
zero based budget which I know Toby
already said but that was the big deal I
mean we've tried budgeting throughout
our marriage but it never really worked
until we did the zero-based and of
course we loved every dollar it makes it
a lot easier oh your own neighbor dollar
calm yes very cool good good good so
what is the biggest budget fight that
you had and
for months hey we don't fight you're a
liar - yeah actually been married 20
years this year and we've never had a
money buy ever know you are very weird
very rare yeah because he just did what
you said or what we did it yes dear okay
all right cool so you just need you
really just need a tractor run on is
what you're saying and you found ya
Total Money Makeover told you how to do
what you already knew to do right that's
the only difference that one like we
showed you new things we just showed you
a new way to do them have y'all been
married 20 years have you ever been
debt-free in your marriage until now for
the first six months or so I think we
got married when we were right at 18 so
we got our first loan probably two or
three months after we got me yeah and
since then for 20 years yeah
and now how's it feel to be debt-free
now feels good
good for you guys alright Toby and
Christy Maya and Joel Hopkinsville
Kentucky area a hundred and sixty-six
thousand dollars paid off in 34 months
making around 80 a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream all right
you all ready three two one well done I
love it you guys congratulations
very well done that's fun you guys would
be so rich so fast and be able to do so
much not only for yourselves and for
your family but for others